[Music]
in a garage on a Crawley Business Park
Engineers are hoping to change energy
for good
this tube undergoing tests can collect
warmth from the Sun and turn it into
heat for big commercial buildings and
much of their hot water it could more
than halve gas consumption but to make a
difference to The Net Zero Target the
company needs to grow and for that it
needs government help the Technologies
to help with the energy transition are
already out there they need the raising
awareness they need the policy support
they need the financial support to get
them on buildings get businesses and
communities saving money and doing it in
a cleaner way the government has
outlined a raft of new measures that it
says will deliver energy security and
climate targets they include a rebranded
insulation scheme to upgrade 300 000 of
the UK's least energy efficient homes a
boost to the electric vehicle charging
infrastructure and plans for new
projects to capture carbon from industry
and either use it or store it
underground but the strategy could still
fall short there is now a global race in
Green Tech but Britain is barely on the
start blocks homegrown companies the
United States have been given incentives
worth hundreds of billions of dollars
startups here need help to catch up fast
it's not just net zero that's at stake
it's the jobs of the future
the High Court ruled last summer that
the government's strategy for reaching
Net Zero was inadequate 75 million tons
of carbon dioxide hadn't been accounted
for equivalent to the annual emissions
from all the cars in the UK this lawyer
who was part of the action warned she
could be back in court we will be
looking very carefully
um at this revised strategy and seeing
whether it does stack up or whether it
is indeed just kicking the can down the
road but under the climate change act
sections 13 and 14 do require plans and
policies to enable upcoming carbon
budgets to be met so it you know this
isn't just some sort of wishy-washy
requirement this is something that is
hard edged from the vast floods of
Pakistan to the scorching heat wave in
the UK the last year has underlined how
climate change is accelerating
scientists and environmental campaigners
worn efforts to reduce carbon need to be
ramped up and it's far from Clear
whether the new strategy does enough
Thomas More Sky News